The Joe Rogan Experience
I hope this guy claims
[Music]
I was just reading through it he claims
he's the one who found the bullet in the
car
placed it on the gurney next to
Kennedy's body like he's the one who
found the Magic Bullet oh yeah but ask
that guy about ghosts
me every he also happened to me it just
means the lottery numbers but I don't
play it because it's not ethical he's
selling a book that's coming out of
course but of course Sam is it possible
it was the Harvard oh he's one of the
Secret Service agents that makes it more
interesting he was a secret service
agent educate Brian on Lee Harvey Oswald
well have you ever seen the video where
the the secret cervicus gets pulled off
and he's like what do we do what and the
car takes off because they're going down
a different route that's not a real
video that's a real video real video
Brian yeah and what's really crazy with
him the entire time they pulled away
from him the Supreme it's weird because
at all it's his whole trip he's
surrounded like the Beatles and then at
this one point in the plaza there's
nobody around it's really creepy and
you're like what is going on he's in a
convertible yeah did he didn't he say he
wanted to go in a convertible wasn't it
he who said he didn't want a shield
around him I think that I think Kennedy
said I never heard that no I don't have
that you know because they pulled him
off to Chicago
he wanted to go into that conversion in
that convertible you know as soon as
assassination happened they rushed that
computer and wiped that uh convertible
and wiped it down so there's no evidence
so much stuff dude
talking about it was was interesting
because he was talking about Curtis
LeMay and all those guys and it's not
surprising that they would the CIA deep
Mafia roots in Dallas
Jack Ruby
yeah
he's talking about Biden and the votes
and all that the numbers to and whether
that makes sense or not dude
[Music]
dude got it for him in Chicago
because it was Dad yeah you [__]
idiot
yeah you know the only thing I have the
only conspiracies here that does make
some sense to me is like the only one
ever yeah yeah what about Enron what
about the scandalous
and Ron was a conspiracy and they did
time what about the Gulf of Tonkin
operation northward but I'm saying
that's the craziest one operation
Northwoods was but but hold on here we
go this is the best operation northwards
was a was The Joint Chiefs of Staff came
up with a bunch of different suggestions
for the president Brian they signed that
the joint Jesus have signed off on
operation Northwoods which means they
were gung-ho to blow up a jetliner and
blame it on Cuba Cuban friendlies and
attack Guantanamo Bay they wanted to
give us motivation to go to a woman so
excuse me but when the President says to
his joints when he says to his military
brass he says come up with different
scenarios of what we do with this
problem everything is on the table you
get a thousand Killing American
civilians
that's a conspiracy and Kennedy said
Brian no yeah he's a conspiracy he's 100
conspiracy to lie to the American people
through blowing up a jet it is a plan to
lie to the American but they conspired
to create a scenario that did not exist
they were going to blow up a jetliner
they're going to attack Cuban friendlies
they're going to kill Americans so the
public Gets behind it
again guys do you think that's not
that's not accurate Brian do you think
they just took those plans and threw
them out oh he doesn't like them let's
just throw them out in the trash what
happens is your the military comes to
your civilian infrastructure your
president the executive says here are
the suggestions Kennedy said no no no
and no this is not constant what are the
other ones there are legal issues what
are the other ones other than operation
Northwoods that he did that with there
were scenarios that would get us into
war Iran Contra no no that would get us
into war with Cuba by the way that's
another conspiracy that was real not
only that the sandinistas and the the
when the um the Contra is in the sand
dunes as far and they sold cocaine in
Los Angeles to fund that that's another
good experience
I'm not saying that Rogue elements
that's the only conspiracy you believe
in because that's not true Brian weapons
of mass destruction just was a big
miscalculation oh no let me be clear
like parts of the government whether
it's State Department Department defense
there are P there are elements within
those who want to push an agenda forward
and will bend rules and do things that
are okay if they can yes right we have a
lot of examples do you think they can
Inspire to do that Brian I'm sorry did
they conspire to do that they do
conspire to do that but but
we find out about these things why
you're the perfect guy to do a show like
this with Sam tripley by the way I know
that's why because you're so bad about
everybody
you're so bad at defending the Deep
State you make everybody a Sam tripley
fan
I love it
so what I'm saying is that there are a
lot of competing interests yeah yeah
when you two got together I was so happy
because it was like Sam's gonna crack
yeah yeah it's a matter of time Sam's
not stupid he just goes so deep that
sometimes he's not really in water
anymore like he's in the Bedrock yeah
yeah it's like Sam you got to go a
little higher the reason okay The Joint
she's a staff document the reason they
were held so long is The Joint Chiefs
never wanted these up because they were
so embarrassing exactly yeah because
they [__] asked for it the whole
point of a democracy is to have leaders
responding to the public will and here
this is the complete reverse the
military trying to trick the American
people into a war Brian that they want
that they want but nobody else wants you
got this on putin.com and I want you
that's on ABC News son that's ABC News